here are three people whose record on
covid-19 shouldn't be forgotten Anthony
fauci tried to pretend that lockdowns
were not his fault but let's be clear
fauci used his position as the top
government Health advisor in the country
to advocate for prolonged closures he
was saying people will die if you don't
shut everything down teachers union
leader Randy Weingarten was ideally
placed to advocate for kids and what
they needed was to go back to school
instead she vigorously opposed president
Trump's plan to reopen schools calling
it Reckless callous and cruel and if she
had her way kids would probably still be
forced to wear masks when Joe Biden was
running for president he said the
coveted vaccine shouldn't be mandatory a
year later once he was in the white
house he flip-flopped and ordered a
vaccine mandate for 80 million workers
to stop the spread then Biden declared
you're not going to get kovid if you
have these vaccinations but although
vaccines offer significant protection
that's not true vaccinated people get
copied all the time it even happened to
Biden himself